Frankfurt die Wirtschaftsmetropole von
hier aus entlang der A66 starten wir
unsere Tour vor allem in den kleineren
Orten rechts und links der Autobahn in
Richtung Osten gab es schon bei den
letzten Wahlen viel Zustimmung für die
AFD wir wollen wissen wie ist dort die
Stimmung jetzt ein paar Tage vor den
Landtagswahlen unsere erste Station ist
Freigericht offenbar ist dort heute
Markttag wir sprechen gleich einen
Händler an wir wüssten gerne äh was so
das Hauptproblem ist politisch was hier
die Leute
beschäftigt ja ich
denke Gefahr von rechts ich möchte
wissen was genau er meint was die
Kundschaft erzählt meistens ging es um
die Flüchtlinge sagt der Blumenhändler
es wird gesagt dass wir die
rausschmeißen sollen dass dies das das
ist nicht schön spüren Sie einen
Rechtsruck im Lande ja das merkt man
überall wo sie hingucken und da brauchen
sie nicht in Osten gucken wir gehen
weiter zur Eisdiele und lernen Paula
vonseeka kennen sie kommt aus Portugal
und ist die Inhaberin wo sieht sie die
Probleme im Ort früher habe ich immer
z.B nach den Arbeit immer alleine
gelaufen ohne Angst heute habe ich Angst
wovor ja
weil jede Ecke stten Männer mit Messer
und also ich bin selbst Ausländer ne
aber wir sind in Deutschland wir mussen
die Deutsch machen wir muss richtig
integrieren und alles machen wie die
Deutsch fertig passiert sei ihr konkret
noch nichts die Flüchtlinge aber sieht
sie dennch kritisch ich seh ihr viele
Familien mit sechs sieben Kinder mama
Papa nicht am arbeiten und ich muss
morgenens bis abends Schafen und dann
mein Geld geht alles um Steuer und das
ganz ehrlich haben wir auch keine Lust
mehr zurück zum Markt wir merken bald
die Migration hat alle anderen
Wahlkampfthemen wie Bildung Wirtschaft
oder Arbeit verdrängt wir haben das
Thema mit den Flüchtlingen wie bringen
wir so unter da wird viel diskutiert es
ist auch zu erwarten dass die AFD mehr
stimmenzuwchsel hat haben sie eine
Erklärung
dafür ja das ist die die Suche nach dem
starken Mann und den einfachen Lösungen
das hatten wir ja alles in Deutschland
schon mal und ich habe da Angst vor wir
fahren Stück weiter in Richtung Osten
nach gellenausen Arm wirken die Orte
hier nicht und es gibt auch nicht mehr
Arbeitslose als woanders die 20.000
Einwohnerstadt gellenausen hat eine
starke AFD erzählt uns Alexander
schopbach er organisiert deshalb jede
Woche eine Mahnwache gegen Rechts und
glaubt dass das Erstarken der rechten in
der Gegend auch mit der ländlichen
Strukturschwäche zusammenhängt nehmen
sie den Ausbau des ÖPNV nehmen Sie die
medizinische Grundversorgung
wo machen die meisten Hausärzte dicht wo
möchte sich kein junger Mediziner mehr
ansiedeln im ländlichen Raum wir haben
dort also eine Verdichtung der
Problemstellungen die den Bürger direkt
betreffen und das macht den Bürger umso
anfälliger für den Wolf im Schafspelz
für die AFD nächstes Ziel ist eine
Wahlkampfveranstaltung der Alternative
für Deutschland in batsodensal Münster
stimmten schon bei der letzten
Landtagswahl über 18% Wähler für die
AFD Beatrix von Storch ist gekommen und
auch hier ist Migration das Reizthema
wir lernen wie negative Ereignisse in
einen Zusammenhang mit Flüchtlingen
gebracht werden unser Land zuerst die
Meinung vertrete ich übrigens auch bevor
unsere Menschen im Atal nicht wieder
vernünftig leben haben hat kein
Asylsuchender das Recht in vier
Sternhotel untergebracht zu werden so
geht's also nicht weiter W überschwendt
was eine Regierungsbeteiligung der AFD
in Hessen denn da ausrichten könne
fragen
wir auf jeden Fall mal die
Grenzsicherung das ist erstmal wichtig
das können Sie schon mal machen und der
Asyl braucht der kann natürlich
reinkommen ist kein Thema aber dann
nicht alle weil wir für euch sind sind
sie gegen uns wir und sie auf diese
Spaltung setzt die AFD wir fahren in die
Nähe von Neuhof zu einer appotheke und
sprechen Markus koppenhöl an er arbeitet
als Entsorger für Altmetall wo drückt
der Schuh
politisch es müsste halt viel getan
werden hier das ist das Problem und es
wird ja nur irgendwo rüber odüber
geschoben aber nie irgendwo richtig was
angegangen genauso der selbst der der
das eigedor da mit der mit mit den
Heizungen das ist für mich Schwachsinn
ohne Ende aber irgendwo muss man ja in
so eine ökologische Richtung gehen beim
Heizen das ist richtig ja aber das muss
man nicht den Leut vor die NAS knallle
damit das von heute auf mor passieren
soll und es gibt nicht nur Leute die
bisschen mehr Geld verdienen unsere
Rentner die stehen dann da und wissen
nicht was sie machen sollen ja ist das
bei Ihnen auch eine Motivation warum sie
sagen diesmal AFD auch mit ja ja in
Neuhof stimmten bereits 2018 über 24%
der Wähler für die AFD wir lernenona und
ja hat ja keine ausländ ja ja auf jeden
Fall na so mit dieser ganzen
Energiepolitik ne das ist das kann man
man kann nicht alles den Bürgern zumuten
dem arbeitenden Volk ne und dann die
anderen kommen kriegen alles ne und ja
nee so geht das nicht ich sage mal wir
sind jetzt auch in dem Rentenalter und
irgendwie
ne denkt man dann schon mal ja kann ich
mir das angesichts der der h und Preise
die jetzt gefordert werden der Inflation
und so weiter kann ich mir überhaupt
noch das alles leisten zum Schluss
müssen wir Deutschen hier raus ne und
und woanders in der Türkei oder irgendwo
unterkommen ne und die Ausländer sind
alle hier we die kriegen ja alles ne und
wir müssen sehen dass wir irgendwo
ja und da kommen wo wir mit dem bisschen
Rente was wir hier uns schwer erarbeitet
haben leben können ne ihre Schwester
Ilona lebt nicht hier sondern in
SachsenAnhalt ich würde die nie ums
Verrecken wählen und was denkst du was
die
machen ja die setzen sich fest und dann
hab wie 39 bis
45 nein das würde kein Mensch mehr
zulassen Ilona und Carola wollen weiter
ich gehe zu einem cffe in der Nähe ich
möchte wissen wie die Leute hier zur AFD
stehen Simon Jürgen ist wütend die AFD
sei eine richtige Gefahr leen
auf gefragt wie der Adolf an die Macht
gekommen ist aber mittlerweile weiß ich
wie der an die Macht gekommen ist da
durch dass die Bundespolitik einfach nur
scheiße baut auf deutsch gesagt wird die
AFD immer stärker mit ihren
populistischen Themen kennt er selbst
Leute die diesmal die AFD wählen werden
von allen Parteien praktisch laufen die
schahenweise zur
AFD damit irgendwann mal einer geht
diskutiert nur passiert aber nichts
passiert absolut gar nichts wo passiert
nicht wo passiert nichts die Ausweisung
z von bekannten das passiert NS dass man
die Grenzen dass mal richtig alles
europaweit geregelt wird so wie einer
Vorschlag macht ist der andere sofortte
gegen unsere Endstation ist Fulda ein
traditionell konservativer Wahlkreis auf
dem Universitätsplatz verteilt die AFD
Thüringer Rostbratwürste eine Anspielung
auf den ersten AFD Landrat Sesselmann in
Thüringen der Andrang ist groß und die
Flüchtlinge sind auch hier das
aufregera ja die vielen Leute hier und
leben von unseren Steuern ja es ist doch
so weil sie verfolgt werden nee also da
gibt's ja auch noch andere Länder wo man
reingehen kann aber hier kriegen seh ja
Geld das ist der Unterschied und meinen
sie dass die AFD da eine bessere
Migrationspolitik machen kann ja ja und
wie ich bin auf jeder Veranstaltung von
der AFD und was könnte die AFD da besser
machen was könnte besser machen das weiß
ich auch nicht vor dem Stand lernen wir
ein AFD Mitglied kennen dass die Partei
in Teilen als verfassungsfeindlich gilt
ficht ihn nicht an das würde ich jetzt
nicht überbewerten die Tatsache dass es
vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird
weil man muss ja beachten was da für
Maßstäbe angelegt werden der Thüringer
Landesverband der AFD gilt als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch kein Problem sagt
Zell ja ich bin selber auch heckan ich
finde das was h sagt finde ich in weiten
Teilen richtig hier in Fulda spüren wir
deutlich wie mit der AFD auch die Angst
vor ihr wächst weil wir dann das hätten
was wir unter Hitler haben hatten
nämlich einen rechtslosen Staat früher
hatten die Springerstiefel an und
klatzen den rechten Pöbel möchte ich
nicht
haben die geben sich in Hessen eher
bürgerlich ja das ist immer so das ist
immer so dass man sich bürgerlich gibt
aber dann Ende kommt was schreckliches
raus was befürchten sie ganz konkret
ganz ganz konkret
dass der rechtsstab abgeschafft wird und
da sind sie auch wenn sie hören wie sie
zur EU stehen und da kann man erkennen
wohin der Wind weht ja wir fahren zurück
mit dem Eindruck dass die Zustimmung zur
AFD aber auch ihre Gegnerschaft entlang
der A66 immer größer
wurde